[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
los periodistas son los invitados y Con
quienes conversamos de manera mucho más
distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos más destacados de la semana para
conversar sobre los temas que hemos
seleccionado para este programa
saludamos a Ginebra bafigo ella es
analista Internacional de la cadena
América Televisión y canal n en Perú
Ginebra Gracias por estar con nosotros y
qué tal termina su semana bienvenida
Muchas gracias gracias por la invitación
Bueno ha sido una semana muy complicada
diría una semana un poco agitada
Claro que sí también saludamos aquí en
el estudio de France 24 a nikolay abril
él es periodista de temas
internacionales también tiene un máster
en periodismo de agencia es jefe de
emisión de los informativos de la cadena
ntn24 Nicolás bienvenido Gracias por
estar con nosotros y cómo termina usted
su semana Santiago qué tal termina con
mucha incertidumbre una guerra en curso
que va a cumplir ya Próximamente un año
y en medio de estas tensiones las
tensiones entre China y Estados Unidos
muchos temas a nivel mundial y también a
nivel regional en América Latina hay
muchos temas moviéndose vamos a analizar
algunos de ellos ustedes también
acompañennos con sus opiniones y sus
comentarios también con sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
arroba franz24 guión bajo ese arroba
santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios es numeral una semana en el
mundo f24 todo pegado todo junto para
que dejen allí sus comentarios pues
hablábamos de temas de América Latina
justamente Nicaragua a lo largo de los
últimos días ha sido justicia debido a
esa decisión del presidente Daniel
Ortega de liberar a 222 presos políticos
que fueron enviados directamente hasta
Estados Unidos a esta decisión hay que
Añadir un factor importante y es que fue
tomada de manera unilateral no hubo
negociaciones con Estados Unidos el
gobierno del país centroamericano
también decidió quitarle la ciudadanía
de nicaragüense motivo por el que por
ejemplo España abrió las puertas y les
ofreció poder optar por la ciudadanía
española a todos estos 222 presos
políticos liberados solamente el
gobierno de chile y también algunos
comentarios han venido por parte de
Colombia han condenado de manera
enérgica esta medida tomada en Managua
el resto de América Latina parece que ha
guardado silencio un silencio cómplice
se lo pregunto a Ginebra en la Ciudad de
Lima Ginebra un silencio cómplice por
parte de los gobiernos latinoamericanos
bueno seguramente un silencio que en
este momento puede ser oportuno por
fines locales no lo que es cierto es que
se va nuevamente a confirmar cierta
tendencia en particular en algunos
gobiernos de izquierda en nuestra región
que no suelen tener el mismo
en la misma manera de juzgar por ejemplo
los regímenes más extremos de la
izquierda como Nicaragua ha demostrado
justamente en los últimos días pero
también acerca de Venezuela los
pronunciamientos son siempre un poco
tibios incluso hemos visto como se han
reanudado las relaciones comerciales
justamente ayer fue una con Colombia
Entonces es una un creo que falta un
poco de
iniciativa en ese sentido porque sí ha
sido una destierro más que una una
liberación de presos políticos sí
desterrados a Estados Unidos y sin la
ciudadanía nicaragüense Ginebra le damos
la palabra ahora Nicolás aquí en el
estudio de France 24 un silencio como ya
decíamos cómplice como por lo menos en
el caso de Colombia el gobierno Petro ya
aprendió que a Nicaragua no se le puede
dejar la silla vacía como ocurrió el año
pasado en la Organización de Estados
Americanos ya está diciendo que no se le
puede retirar la nacionalidad a estos
nicaragüenses de hecho Las Naciones
Unidas Ya dijeron que esto va en contra
del derecho internacional por lo menos
estamos viendo un paso que está tomando
ya Gustavo Petro que no había tomado
antes y esperemos que con ese espíritu
de Liderazgo que quiere tener en la
izquierda latinoamericana los demás
países se fijan en ello y empiecen a
hablar porque ya nos dimos cuenta con el
caso de Venezuela que eso no puede pasar
que no puede haber silencios Cómplices
si por el momento la región ha sido
bastante lenta a la hora de pronunciarse
sobre este tema usted como lo ve Nicolás
es una medida desesperada del gobierno
Ortega Cuál es la coyuntura en este país
para que el gobierno de Daniel Ortega
haya tenido que tomar esta decisión o
Esto va a darle buenos frutos en un
futuro cómo lo analizas yo más que
desespero veo en el régimen de Nicaragua
una demostración de fuerza no sabemos
que está pasando detrás de bambalinas
Estados Unidos dice que esto fue un
gesto unilateral por parte del régimen
de Daniel Ortega que está sancionado a
todas luces por Washington y es una
demostración de fuerza porque está
diciendo yo les estoy excarcelando a
estos presos políticos pero todavía
tengo poder sobre ellos como quitándoles
la nacionalidad sí y qué piensa Ginebra
su opinión
Bueno la verdad que me parece la el
última La Última instancia de un régimen
para eliminar la la oposición en este
caso en particular lo que estamos viendo
lo que estamos registrando es que
incluso aquellos en este caso me refiero
a la Obispo Álvarez quien se negó a
aceptar esas condiciones es decir el
destierro terminó incluso con una pena
26 años de cárcel es decir la arremetida
de Daniel Ortega es incluso más violenta
de lo que habíamos pensado inicialmente
se está agravando la situación en
Nicaragua y claramente es
Sí una digamos el la evolución casi
natural de un régimen como el de Daniel
Ortega Nicaragua y coincidiendo con
Ginebra yo creo que aquí lo que vale la
pena Resaltar es que se está trazando
una hegemonía comunicacional no que
solamente sea la voz del régimen la que
se escuche en Nicaragua se ha callado a
prensa independiente 100% noticias sus
líderes ahora están en el exilio no
tienen la nacionalidad nicaragüense el
régimen lo que quiere es que solamente
esté la versión oficial Sí y eso lo
vemos que eso implica que se haya
callado a personas que eran muy cercanas
a Daniel Ortega veíamos incluso a
excompañeros de lucha durante la época
de la guerra civil en Nicaragua de la
lucha sandinista que fueron expulsados
fueron desterrados y hoy en día están en
Estados Unidos cuando en el pasado
combatieron hombro a hombro con Daniel
Ortega por eso por esos ideales contra
la dictadura de somoza lo que se
pregunta uno y es tal vez uno de los
análisis obligados que hemos tenido que
hacer en las redacciones en los
diferentes medios es esto qué peso va a
ejercer sobre el gobierno de Daniel
Ortega esto qué peso le va a traer de la
comunidad internacional ya vemos que por
lo menos rechazo o críticas o
señalamientos por parte de la de América
Latina ha sido lento pero a nivel
mundial esto qué peso le va a generar a
Nicaragua ginebra
bueno Es probable que hayan más
sanciones ya hemos visto lamentablemente
no en Latinoamérica pero sí hubo
importantes y pronunciamientos por
ejemplo desde Estados Unidos España en
particular se mostró muy solidaria pero
también la mayoría de los gobiernos
europeos sí se han pronunciado con una
una condena firme acerca de este exilio
forzoso al que se están sometiendo unas
más de 200 presos políticos y entre
ellos lo interesante que es claramente
si hay políticos como estábamos diciendo
en el en el estudio también pero también
hay un líder estudiantil quien tuvo lo
sabía Según a Daniel Ortega de llamarlo
asesino cuando se estaba justamente
buscando una salida la crisis y a las
protestas del 2019 Pero además hay
también
varios periodistas Entonces es lo más
probable que pueda ocurrir ahora es una
mayor presión y un mayor aislamiento de
agua en el contexto internacional vamos
a ver efectivamente acá lo que el papel
la clave lo van a jugar los países
latinoamericanos que están tal vez
tomando tiempo Tal vez están todavía con
ese silencio cómplice del que hablábamos
antes de todas formas yo creo que
a Estados Unidos se le ha criticado
también que ha actuado bastante suave no
el comunicado que lanzó Anthony blinken
después de esta excarcelación de presos
políticos en Nicaragua Fue bastante
dócil es decir alabó consideró como un
paso positivo esas excarcelaciones ese
destierro y no dijo nada sobre la
pérdida de nacionalidad que es un
derecho fundamental aquí lo que Estados
Unidos podría estar apostando es y es
suave para ver qué tanto puede ir
avanzando y de todas formas frente a sus
críticos que lo cuestionan por su
suavidad demostrar otros logros no por
ejemplo las excarcelaciones en Venezuela
con los dirigentes de circo por ejemplo
con la de la basquetbolista
estadounidense que estaba presa en Rusia
la basquetbolista entonces de pronto
Esas son las estrategias no quisiéramos
ver más contundencia más fuerza Pero hay
todavía mesura claro y ahí Bueno ahí por
lo menos de por medio hay una
negociación con Caracas y con Moscú con
el kremli en este caso de acuerdo a lo
que dijo Daniel Ortega no hubo ningún
tipo de negociación con Washington
simplemente Managua informó a Estados
Unidos y le dijo voy a excarcelar a
estas personas las vamos a enviar a
Estados Unidos y Estados Unidos facilitó
el ingreso de ellos a través de
diferentes procesos migratorios que
tienen
para este tipo de situaciones pero pone
sobre la mesa una figura que lo
mencionaba Ginebra que a mí me ha
llamado mucho la atención y quiero
conocer la opinión de ustedes y es el
destierro que era lo hemos dicho en
otros programas de France 24 es casi que
una figura medieval que ha venido otra
vez a quedar sobre la mesa y que nadie
ha criticado nadie ningún organismo
internacional ha venido a explicar qué
es el destierro ni en qué no existe ni
esto dentro de los derechos
internacionales funciona o no o esto En
qué Marco está porque se ha llevado un
poco más de protagonismo lo el la
eliminación de la de la ciudadanía
nicaragüense le doy la palabra
nicolágeno es usted perder la
nacionalidad usted queda en el Limbo A
quién pertenece a dónde pertenece Cuál
es su casa cuáles son sus raíces es como
tratar de Eliminar todo ese universo que
esa persona tenía concebida para Sí y lo
deja prácticamente abandonado por suerte
ya Estados Unidos por supuesto les ha
dado este periodo de dos años de Gracia
un periodo humanitario y España también
ha intercedido para de alguna manera
hacerle contrapeso a esa medida que como
decía ya fue cuestionada incluso por las
Naciones Unidas porque es una violación
flagrante del derecho internacional Pero
qué tal el destierro usted cómo lo
interpreta es una forma
justamente trazar una misma narrativa Yo
creo que es el paso fácil de Abel Ortega
de deshacerse de sus críticos en casa y
decir yo aquí en casa puedo hacer lo que
yo quiera porque estoy al mando y no
tengo críticos mis críticos están afuera
además garantiza que están lejos y a
quitarles la ciudadanía que no regresen
ellos no pueden pisar ahora Nicaragua de
ninguna manera
su opinión sobre esta figura del
destierro
Bueno yo no sé sinceramente Cuando lo
cuando leí el cable cuando me enteré de
la noticia me pareció muy interesante
desde un punto de vista tanto simbólico
como semántico es decir si nosotros
consideramos que había todavía unos
doscientos presos políticos en nada
Nicaragua hoy en día no solo ya no están
en Nicaragua sino que ya técnicamente no
se le puede decir que son opositores
nicaragüenses porque ya no tienen ni
siquiera la nacionalidad por lo menos
según Daniel Ortega Entonces el mensaje
es Claro ya dejan de ser nuestra
oposición simplemente son las dos
centenares de apátridas que durante dos
años probablemente se van a quedar en
Estados Unidos que es además el país que
sabemos un país de básicamente del Gran
Enemigo en el discurso en La retórica de
Ortega sino que finalmente ya nos ya no
son un problema cercano y ya no son ni
siquiera un problema
en sus palabras no eso es a lo que a mí
me ha parecido más interesante acerca
del destierro y coincido totalmente
acerca del hecho que es una figura algo
medieval No escuchábamos eso del
destierro desde cuánto en realidad claro
el problema es que lo vayan a empezar a
a copiar o a seguir otros regímenes
alrededor del mundo para ir cerrando
este tema de Nicaragua de avanzar con
nosotros temas de la agenda pensemos en
lo que viene más adelante para este país
centroamericano ahora que Daniel Ortega
ha desterrado a estos
líderes opositores y presos políticos
ellos ahora van a tener voz a nivel
mundial van a ir a diferentes medios de
comunicación a dar a conocer su versión
de los hechos las torturas por las que
tuvieron que pasar los procesos legales
que tuvieron que enfrentar sin ningún
tipo de argumentos válidos todo esto lo
van a dar a conocer Todo esto le va a
jugar en contra el presidente Ortega en
cierta forma hago la ronda la inversa
con nicolate yo creo que
ya la hemos visto con el caso de
Venezuela Cuántos exiliados venezolanos
no hay por el mundo denunciando la
situación de Venezuela claro es una
situación que se hace más conocida a
nivel internacional así lo va a ser
también la situación de Nicaragua si es
que se
había mantenido de alguna manera más en
la retaguardia Pero qué ha pasado con el
liderazgo de la oposición se ha
desvanecido Leopoldo López Carlos
vecchio esas figuras se han ido
amainando mientras el régimen de
Venezuela sigue perpetuándose Yo pienso
que a futuro es lo que vamos a ver Puede
que haya una mala prensa internacional
una mala imagen para el régimen de
Daniel Ortega pero en casa va a tener
todas sus anchas Sí además tiene toda la
institucionalidad a su favor Ginebra su
conclusión sobre este tema de Nicaragua
y lo que viene para Ortega
Bueno lo lamentable es que no creo que
la firma de ese régimen sea tan cercano
Y es más a este última arremetida lo que
nos dice es que ha ganado más poder y
que seguramente por lo menos la paradoja
del discurso estadounidense era esa
celebra El Paso dado y que van a
conversar acerca de los Derechos Humanos
cuando hemos visto Este destierro ha
sido claramente una violación de los
mismos yo lo que temo es que este no sea
todavía el ocaso de este régimen en la
Centroamérica francamente así como no lo
fue Cuando surgió la oposición
venezolana el chavismo y el de Nicolás
maduro entonces seguramente el hecho de
que haya una
un grupo importante de opositores en el
exterior puede ayudar a visibilizar lo
que es el problema en Nicaragua Pero no
creo que sea tampoco la solución así las
cosas y también muchos analistas lo han
dicho ya esto Abre sin duda alguna un
nuevo episodio en esta crisis política
que está viviendo Nicaragua que está
viviendo este país centroamericano pero
ahora con la particularidad de tener a
figuras clave de la oposición y a
figuras clave que podían hacerle
contrapeso Ortega en un posible
escenario electoral rumbo a la
presidencia están fuera de las fronteras
de Nicaragua eso es bastante
inusual Cerramos el tema de Nicaragua y
pasamos a hablar de Colombia porque esta
semana fue semana de manifestaciones en
ese país suramericano las principales
calles de diferentes ciudades de ese
país fueron el escenario de marchas
tanto a favor de las medidas del
presidente Gustavo Petro como también
para expresar su descontento por algunas
medidas y propuestas que tiene bajo la
manga el mandatario de los colombianos
ha recibido numerosas críticas y también
señalamientos desde diferentes sectores
de la sociedad por su ambicioso Pero
también poco claro plan de reformas de
Gran calibre al sistema de salud al
sistema laboral de pensiones que siguen
aún ya aprobado plan de reforma
tributaria algunos ciudadanos en las
calles también criticaron esos diálogos
de paz con la guerrilla del eln que
tiene lugar en México y también critican
su propuesta de paz total Tal parece que
para los colombianos todavía no es muy
claro Qué significa este esta propuesta
de paz total se acabó entonces la luna
de miel entre el presidente Petro y la
ciudadanía entre los colombianos hago la
ronda la inversa con nikolay se acabó si
tenemos en cuenta que después de empezar
favorablemente su gobierno ha ido
perdiendo apoyo en las calles en la
ciudadanía si tenemos en cuenta que su
favorabilidad cayó ocho puntos la semana
pasada dejándolo ahora en el 35%, se
acabó esa luna de miel si tenemos en
cuenta que hay voces disidentes dentro
de su propio gabinete que dicen no
fuimos consultados en el caso de la
Reforma a la salud se acabó esa luna de
miel cuando vemos preocupación dentro
del Congreso sectores senadores que han
estado apoyando a Gustavo Petro como es
el caso de Roy barreras que ahora lo
están cuestionando justamente porque
Aparentemente ha ido más allá
Ginebra su opinión Cómo es la
perspectiva de la situación de Colombia
estando en Lima desde fuera de las
fronteras colombianas
Bueno si fue una luna de miel ha sido
breve no se cumplen apenas unos seis
meses de mandato de Gustavo Petro hemos
visto esta semana la publicación de una
encuesta una encuesta en la que la de la
desaprobación había subido hasta el 53%
si no me equivoco entonces hay un poco
de malestar en particular me imagino que
es por el tema de la incertidumbre se
estaba proponiendo un cambio radical
pero todavía hemos podido por ejemplo
analizar el texto de la Reforma la salud
pero se vienen muchas más reformas y
todavía no sabemos exactamente más de lo
que se plantea en discursos en los que
Petro está buscando además el respaldo
de la calle no sabemos exactamente de
qué se va a tratar Cómo se van a
implementar estas reformas y lo otro es
el trámite que ha sido cuestionado
Incluso en el congreso colombiano por
congresistas tanto de de la oposición
pero también una de algunos partidos del
gobierno así como justamente estaban
mencionando el problema es también un
poco burocrático el trámite de una
reforma que tiene que ver la cuna una
derecho básico fundamental como la salud
ya finalmente está pasando por un
trámite muy rápido lo cual va a poder
incluso evitar mucho el debate no
Ginebra continuó con usted y le pregunto
Aprovechando que usted está fuera de
Colombia y que usted pueda hacer un
análisis de una perspectiva
distinta a la que podemos hacer los que
estamos en Colombia Cómo se ve desde
afuera el análisis que se puede hacer de
estas políticas del presidente Petro
está este afán por hacer reformas lo más
rápido posible pero que son mal
comunicadas a la ciudadanía que son mal
comunicadas incluso a diferentes
instancias de el gobierno esa es una
falla que claramente Es evidente por lo
menos el tema de comunicación tiene
muchos problemas al gobierno le ha
costado generar los canales de
comunicación pero tantas reforma En tan
poco tiempo a la ciudadanía Tal vez eso
no le llega bien Cómo lo analiza a usted
Bueno desde acá Seguramente se percibe
esta visión reformista de Petro Pero por
otro lado también es parte de un cambio
un cambio histórico que se ha dado con
la elección del mismo del presidente de
Colombia en la primera presidente de
izquierda de la historia colombiana en
la el hecho de que se necesiten
especialmente en una región no solo
Colombia sino una región tan desigual
como la latinoamericana una serie de
reformas si puede tener una buena
acogida lo que sí preocupa es Si esas
son reformas estructurales o si
simplemente están reflejando también una
visión política porque Pedro ha ganado
pero para su mandato la reforma
estructural queda entonces ahí yo creo
que es la preocupación que además
me imagino que será también en Colombia
no solo desde afuera nosotros lo vemos
así además lo que nos ha llamado la
atención es el hecho de que ciertas
reformas no estén pasando por ejemplo a
través las comisiones constitucionales
de las cámaras no Entonces eso ya a mí
por ejemplo me llama mucho la atención y
sí para mí es una alarma me espía claro
una sirena de alarma
Nicolás por este lado acá en el estudio
su opinión muchas reformas al mismo
tiempo muy ambicioso el plan y también
que cómo analiza usted el tema de la
comunicación de estos temas Ginebra
decía la palabra incertidumbre yo creo
que eso lo resume todo no solamente
porque se ha hecho una mala tarea en la
comunicación de estas reformas sino que
Aparentemente lo que transmite el
gobierno es que no quiere que se discuta
mucho es decir la reforma a la salud
recién fue presentada este lunes antes
de eso no teníamos mayores visos sobre
cómo iba a funcionar el nuevo régimen se
busca como lo decía Ginebra que esta
reforma sea una discusión
estatutaria Perdón en estatutaria
búscanos congresistas para
abordar ese tema esencial que es el
derecho fundamental de los colombianos
porque estamos hablando de la salud
ahora el gobierno no quiere que sea
estatutaria porque quiere reducir los
tiempos Por qué el gobierno no quiere
que lo discutamos a fondo cuál es el
miedo detrás de eso por qué le pide a
sus bases en la plaza de Bolívar en la
Plaza de Armas de la casa de nariño que
lo apoyen sin ni siquiera conocer la
propuesta recién había salido del horno
claro y eso eso llama mucho la atención
que Durante los días de las
manifestaciones varios medios
colombianos estaban conversando con las
personas congregadas allí en las dos
diferentes marchas tanto a favor como en
contra y les preguntaban por puntos
específicos de la Reforma o si conocían
la reforma y la gran mayoría decían que
no la conocían que no la habían leído
que era un documento de 180 páginas y
que no lo habían leído pero allá estaban
en en manifestación tanto a favor como
en contra esto también habla un poco más
de la sociedad colombiana que
desinformada está yendo a protestar y a
manifestarse de de puntos que a lo mejor
no conoce y eso me lleva a preguntarle a
nicolai un punto importante y son las
manifestaciones normalmente en Colombia
no se manifestaba hemos visto que en los
últimos años los colombianos han perdido
ese miedo de salir a la calle y se dejó
de ver también la manifestación como es
de estudiante de universidad pública en
esta sociedad esta estratificada y
tampoco se se ve más como un una
manifestación de personas que son de la
izquierda Aquí ya está saliendo a la
calle a protestar izquierda derecha los
colombianos Perdieron el miedo a la
calle Yo creo que es que de todas formas
también están en juego nuestros
intereses están en juego muchas reformas
que podrían cambiar durante décadas la
forma en que conocemos a Colombia si
bien es cierto que fue un cambio por el
que apostó el electorado también es
cierto que una gran parte la mitad
prácticamente
ve esto con mucho temor y es legítimo
escuchar a esa otra parte de la
población y es un modelo que de alguna
manera Gustavo Petro está trayendo del
populismo Internacional de Venezuela lo
hemos visto ya en el caso de las marchas
contra marchas a favor del régimen en
contra del régimen y lo que está
haciendo de alguna manera es replicarlo
acá también en Colombia en una plaza en
la que él se siente cómodo lo hemos
visto ya también incluso cuando fue
alcalde de Bogotá en ese balcón del
palacio del Líbano
vociferando a sus anchas interesante ese
ese apunte que hace usted nicolay pasó a
preguntarle a Ginebra por un punto que
une esta discusión entre Colombia y Perú
y es esa decisión del Congreso peruano
con respecto a las declaraciones que
justamente ha dado el presidente Petro
sobre la situación del expresidente
Castillo allí en Perú y la situación que
se ha vivido esta crisis política en la
que está inmersa Perú en los últimos
meses que se puede analizar
Bueno tal vez podemos regresar al punto
inicial no estamos justamente
nos estamos refiriendo eso antes es
decir que en particular algunos
gobiernos de izquierda tienen una doble
lectura de las realidades de los países
vecinos en particular no hemos escuchado
una palabra acerca de Nicaragua Pero
muchas acerca de la situación que
estamos viviendo en el Perú y eso es
interesante efectivamente A qué se debe
exactamente acá ha sido claramente una
declaración
que ha tenido unas consecuencias
evidentes a todo el mundo sabemos cómo
se ha pronunciado finalmente la clase
política peruana acerca de esas
declaraciones pero es interesante que se
digna ese tipo de pronunciamientos por
parte de Gustavo Petro quien ya es el
presidente de Colombia entonces ciertas
declaraciones son
no son las más diplomáticas que podría
dar en un contexto además en que
efectivamente Perú se ha visto un poco
de esa lectura a nivel internacional de
lo que estamos viviendo una lectura que
es un poco parcializada especialmente
gracias al respaldo de algunos gobiernos
regionales para ir cerrando este tema de
Colombia le preguntó a Ginebra qué
podemos esperar para las próximas
semanas en este país en este afloje con
el presidente y sus decisiones y cómo
está empezando a despuntarse y a darse a
conocer la forma de gobernar del
presidente Petro
después de que se terminó ya la luna de
miel porque ya creo que ya la podemos
dar por terminada
sí rápida rápida pero sí efectivamente
la lo que se viene desde mi punto de
vista o que me parece interesante y voy
a estar registrando justamente al ver
que va a pasar en los próximos días es
los niveles de tensión las que se están
registrando dentro del gobierno Petro y
a raíz de la presentación de estas
reformas muy deliciosas Pero sabemos que
la de la del sistema sanitario es solo
la primera Entonces vamos a ver cómo va
escalando esta tensión dentro de la
gobierno y también cuál es la respuesta
del Congreso si efectivamente logran
pasar y cambiar el tipo de trámite
legislativo que si tendría por lo menos
la garantía de un control de la corte
constitucional también no no solo de la
comisión claro finalmente vamos a ver
qué pasa eso sí y Nicolás para cerrar el
tema su conclusión a mí lo que me
preocupa es Cuál es la definición qué es
lo que Petro entiende por democracia
cuando él dice que está defendiendo la
voluntad Popular en las calles y a
través de sus diferentes proyectos me
preocupa porque acaso es
democracia tratar de eliminar lo que
piensa la otra parte de la población que
no votó por él es decir él ganó por un
3% un margen bastante estrecho Y si
recordamos los colombianos no votaron al
parlamento
del Congreso mayoritariamente por
Gustavo Petro después se fue formando
esta coalición de partidos que ahora lo
están respaldando pero es un voto que
hay que tenerse en cuenta ese voto que
llevó a los congresistas actuales fue un
voto también rechazo a algunas de sus
políticas y Esas voces se tienen que
escuchar eso se tiene que debatir eso se
tiene que discutir No simplemente decir
que yo estoy aquí en respaldo de una
población que me votó sino que también
hay otra con la que hay que dialogar y
de hecho lo prometió El Siete de agosto
dijo unir a Colombia este será un
gobierno de puertas abiertas es el
momento para que él lo demuestre bueno Y
es justamente lo que se le critica creo
también claro eso aumenta la
polarización y todos los presidentes
llegan a decir que van a gobernar para
todos pero justo lo que le critican a
los gobiernos anteriores es lo que
terminan haciendo cuando ya están en el
poder de izquierda de derecha de centro
en el norte en el sur el escenario
siempre es más o menos el mismo vamos a
cambiar de tema y pasamos a otro de los
temas destacados de la semana porque
esta semana justamente
Pues también fue bastante destacado en
las diferentes redacciones
internacionales la supuesta amenaza de
China a Estados Unidos con globos espías
el pasado 4 de Febrero Estados Unidos
derribó un objeto sospechoso sobre el
Océano Atlántico las autoridades de
Estados Unidos indicaron que se trataba
como lo decía de un globo espía chino
utilizado para diferentes tareas de
vigilancia Beijing Indicó que se trataba
simplemente de un globo meteorológico
civil que perdió su rumbo y se salió de
control desde entonces la atención entre
Beijing y Washington está aumentando con
el paso de los días y de las horas los
diferentes señalamientos van y vienen de
cualquiera de los dos lados y entonces
pues uno se pregunta en este momento
Cuáles son las motivaciones que hay
detrás de esta serie de señalamientos
porque un globo lleva a la máxima
atención
a Estados Unidos y China cuando tienen
otros escenarios mucho más complicados
en los que pueden sentarse a debatir y a
discutir o tener discrepancias por
ejemplo
Ginebra su opinión
Bueno la verdad que si bien ha aumentado
las tensiones entre Pekín y Washington a
esta casa al globo podríamos llamarla
así finalmente el creo que el mensaje de
Joe biden es especialmente a uso y
consumo interno me explico en la muchas
veces se le ha criticado de tener una
postura un poco suave acerca de China y
con este enfrentamiento incluso con el
discurso que escuchamos la semana pasada
sobre el estado de la unión
volvió nuevamente a utilizar un tono un
poco más fuerte lo cual puede ayudarlo
Especialmente cuando en un momento en
que él necesita respaldo también de los
republicanos para implementar no solo
sus reformas las que él la quiere dejar
como legado de su presidencia sino
también para las varias medidas
económicas que tiene que implementar en
los en las próximas semanas Nicolás su
opinión Yo creo que aquí lo que se está
haciendo es medir el aceite así como la
unión soviética le medía el aceite a
Estados Unidos en la Guerra Fría parece
estar pasando lo mismo la hacemos este
Globo A ver qué pasa la hacemos este
globo para ver cuál es la reacción de
Estados Unidos dice Pekín que se desvió
por error pero qué coincidencia que ese
globo haya pasado por sitios militares
sensibles que coincidencia que ese globo
o que otro globo haya llegado además a
América Latina nada menos que a Colombia
que son Aliado de Estados Unidos el más
importante en la región cerca a las
aguas venezolanas que es un Aliado de
Beijing y que coincidencia que también
haya pasado por Costa Rica que es un
Aliado de Estados Unidos pero a su vez
un crítico acérrimo del régimen de
Nicaragua eso es importante pero también
hay que decir que Estados Unidos no ha
mostrado las evidencias que garanticen
que efectivamente este globo es un globo
de espionaje esa es la gran deuda
pendiente que tiene la casa blanca para
esclarecer todo esto cómo entienden
ustedes en Nicolás y Ginebra estos
diferentes
que se abren de conflicto entre
Washington y
Beijing ahora es el tema de los Globos
hace unos meses hablábamos de la
atención con Taiwán de vez en cuando
cuando pion yang le da por lanzar algún
tipo de misil entonces vuelve a entrar
China y Estados Unidos sobre Cómo
manejar Corea del Norte las canciones
comerciales es decir es algo que se va
renovando no cíclicamente hay como una
nueva excusa hay una nueva razón y lo
que preocupa en este caso de los Globos
es que se dan un contexto de guerra
actual entre Ucrania y Rusia a propósito
esta semana denunció que globos rusos
también sobrevolaron la capital y se da
también en momentos en que alimentado
por esa narrativa que hay en el kremlin
haya temores de que finalmente china
termine invadiendo Taiwán Esto no es
aislado lo que estamos viendo y sea en
medio de esas situaciones
internacionales en las que insisto se
está midiendo cuál es la respuesta de
Estados Unidos porque es que Estados
Unidos en el caso de Taiwán había dicho
que iba a defender a taipei en caso de
una invasión en enero apenas en enero
acaban de firmar un acuerdo con
filipinas para que las tropas
estadounidenses puedan llegar a las
tropas de allí un poco más al sur en el
Pacífico también así es y cómo hace uno
la lectura desde el lado chino Ginebra
porque aquí vemos a Estados Unidos como
muy eufórico haciendo el convenio con
filipinas acercándose a Taiwán Armando
esta Alianza con con el Reino Unido y
con Australia para poner submarinos en
las costas australianas pero China
Qué puede hacer
china claramente está sabiendo que cómo
puede
imponerse no en Asia Pacífico Ya lo
habíamos visto antes justamente antes de
que se firmara ese acuerdo esta Alianza
entre Reino Unido y Australia también no
habíamos visto como china se estaba
expandiendo también en la base Pacífico
Entonces yo creo que sí china Está
tratando de
seguirla con sus planes y lo que más me
preocupa claramente es que eso se pueda
finalmente concretar en una invasión de
Taiwán como muchos analistas especulan a
que ya sea casi inminente no entonces
las pensiones se pueden ver más sobre
ese frente que el tema de los Globos yo
creo que faltan todavía muchas pruebas
para entender exactamente de que estamos
hablando Más allá de un tema diplomático
que terminó frustrando un importante
reunión bilateral entre el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos
en Canadá y su homólogo chino en Pekín
Ginebra a mí justamente lo que me
preocupa sobre este tema es eso que veo
que los canales diplomáticos entre los
dos países cada vez son más fríos cada
vez son más lejanos y la opción
diplomática y la opción del diálogo se
va dejando de lado hay críticas de lado
y lado pero no ve uno ni a Washington y
a Beijing queriendo conversar sobre este
tema esta atención que viene
acumulándose desde hace varias desde
hace varios meses ya prácticamente un
año qué podemos decir sobre ese tema qué
puede decir
bueno que el diálogo de todas maneras
siempre ha sido un poco complicado entre
dos superpotencias lo que sí
Especialmente los últimos años por qué
porque hay muchos intereses
claramente cada uno Busca lograr el
propio y lo que estamos viendo en
particular con esta administración de
biden es que incluso han aumentado los
ensayos de Corea del Norte de pionyang y
también el lenguaje utilizado por el
régimen norcoreano Entonces
es Lamentablemente un momento en que la
diplomacia internacional no está dando
grandes frutos pero no solo en el
conflicto que se puede dar entre China y
Estados Unidos sino también en Europa me
queda ya pocos minutos para finalizar el
programa un minuto para finalizar y
quiero cerrar preguntándoles Qué temas
van a tener ustedes en la lupa bajo la
lupa para analizar para
mirar a lo largo de la próxima semana en
las redacciones de los medios para los
cuales trabajan Nicolás sin duda el tema
de los Globos porque en los últimos tres
que derribaron en América del Norte
dijeron no son ni extraterrestres no son
ni espías no son ni chinos Entonces qué
son porque si no son extraterrestres
entonces algún ser humano los tuvo que
haber puesto allá arriba eso va a seguir
dando mucho de que hablar a pesar de que
el gobierno de Estados Unidos ha tratado
de rebajar las tensiones diciendo que no
son de China Por otra parte la semana
pasada ya se habló de Turquía Yo creo
que es importante la responsabilidades
de los constructores claro y Ginebra
rápidamente sus temas
bueno seguramente va a seguir viendo
como evoluciona la situación en Turquía
pero también claramente Ucrania ya vamos
a tener que sacar cifras acerca de casi
a hoy y casi un año de conflicto O sea
que esos temas seguramente y los Globos
la verdad que son muy entretenidos
especialmente si la Casa Blanca vuelve a
desmentir que son extraterrestres O sea
que vamos a estar atento y tendremos
también en la lupa Perú porque le
levantaron la inmunidad al expresidente
castillo y eso sin duda alguna va a
empezar a generar revuelo allí en ese
país suramericano Ginebra Nicolás les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros les recuerdo que la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera Pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales Siguen con
nosotros
[Música]